- [Instructor] So I'm here
on the Khan Academy Exercise
for mapping shapes.
And I'm asked to map the
movable quadrilateral
onto quadrilateral ABCD
using rigid transformations.
So here in blue, I have
the movable quadrilateral.
And I want to map it onto
this quadrilateral in gray.
And we have a series of tools here
rigid transformations of translation,
rotation and reflection
on the Khan Academy tool.
And of course, we can undo it.
So the technique I'm
going to use to do this is
I'm gonna first use translation
to make one of the corresponding points
overlap with the point
that it corresponds to.
So, for example, it looks like
this corresponds to
Point C right over here.
And so I am going to translate.
And so notice, once I click that I can
translate this around.
So I'm gonna translate
right over here to Point C.
And now, let's see.
To make
these two overlap
I really can't do anymore translation,
I made one point overlap.
Do I rotate, or do I reflect?
Well, if I eyeball it right over here
it looks like I am doing a rotation.
Let me try to make user rotation to make
this segment eight over here
overlap with segment CD.
So let me do a rotation now.
And so
let's see, yep, this is looking good
There you go.
We did the rotation
and we are done.
Now, let's do another example.
So, here, what do we need to do?
All right, so I'm gonna
do the same technique.
This seems to correspond to Point C
so I'm gonna translate first.
So, translate
first.
And then, there's something interesting
going on right over here.
Because I've actually been able to overlap
points C and A by shifting it.
By translating it, I should say.
And so it's not clear
if I were to rotate it
then I would lose the fact that A
that the point that corresponds to A
is now sitting on top of A.
The point that corresponds to C
is now sitting on top of C.
It feels like a reflection.
And it looks like a
line that would actually
contain the points A and C.
If we reflect over that line
we will be in good shape.
So let me see.
Reflection.
So let me see, move of the line.
See how it looks.
There, that's not what I wanted to do.
So let's see.
Let me move my line.
So that is, I think, a
good line of reflection.
And then let me actually
try to reflect, and there you go.
I was able to reflect over that line.
And my clue that I had
to reflect over the line
that contained A and C is that
the points A and C
and their images
after the transformation
were all sitting on top of each other.
So, that was a good clue
that on a reflection
if they're both sitting
on the line of reflection
that they wouldn't move, so to speak.
And there you have it.
So this was a translation
and then a reflection.